hey good morning to you Charlie right we
want to bring in Governor Cuomo because
he joined in other officials out of
briefing soon after the attack he
promised we will be vigilant his
participation in the Halloween parade in
Greenwich Village is a signal that he
wants the people of New York City to
keep living their lives Governor Andrew
Cuomo is with us now from his New York
City office governor was good to see you
and many others out there at the parade
last night but let me ask you this
morning what are we learning about the
suspect and did he have any accomplices
will the invest in good morning Nora the
investigation is ongoing the best
evidence we have is that he was
quote-unquote a lone wolf model they're
going through social media to see what
connections he may have had there are
very few interactions with law
enforcement he was a truck driver he had
some vehicular violations the State
Police actually helped him and his truck
out of a ditch at one time but there's
no evidence now that it was part of a
larger conspiracy larger plot this is
the evolution of the jihad tactics right
right it's no longer geographically
isolated the Internet has given them a
global platform and a global training
ground and they have a very simple play
rental car rented truck create mayhem
and try to disrupt society and that's
what that's what yesterday was a
depraved coward in my opinion rented a
truck and we lost eight people and
that's terrible but they were not
successful they did not disrupt New York
City they did not disrupt New York State
we went to the Halloween parade we had a
great parade I went myself not because
they had a great costume Nora but
because it was about showing up and New
Yorkers showed up and they did not
instill terror
so they failed
governor I'm standing just about 50
yards in front of that truck that the
terrorists used and is still here out on
the the scene as investigators continue
their work here we're a federal law
enforcement official tells CBS News that
a note was found in that rental truck
that referenced Isis what can you tell
us about that note well again the the
investigations aren't going but yes
there was a note that referenced Isis in
many ways this was now a quote-unquote
classic case of a radicalization of a
domestic jihadist who associated with
Isis and this is their new playbook very
simple use a vehicle to cause harm it's
New York it's London its Germany it's
France its Ohio so this is more of what
we've seen you have to remember New
Yorkers this goes back to 1993 almost 35
years my father was governor when we had
the World Trade Center bombing we lost
six people then we had 9/11 so there
have been many attacks to knock down New
Yorkers they have all failed and look
New York is a target we have that statue
in our harbor that holds the lamp of
freedom and democracy and there are a
lot of haters who want to knock that
lamp out and they've tried before
they'll try again I'm sure and they'll
fail every time I'm sure and one of the
reasons they'll fail governors in part
because of the great work of the NYPD
and I don't want to go without saying in
pointing out the work of 28 year old
Ryan Nash the officer who shot the
suspect and stopped him from carrying
out further attacks how is his condition
today
his condition again I want to leave the
details until the family has spoken to
but he is a hero there is no doubt NYPD
did a great job fire FDNY did a great
job
the FBI FBI the coordination of all
Homeland Security on the federal side
was very helpful National Guard was
helpful unfortunately we've been through
this before we have the best security on
the globe it's the most coordinated and
we have first responders who are heroes
and that's what you saw yesterday and
you've seen before
Governor Cuomo thanks for keeping us up
today we appreciate you joining us this
morning